hi everyone
i'm hideaki nishino and i head up
playstations platform planning and
management team which includes product
and ux design
today we are finally going to give you a
look at the playstation 5 user
experience
we will see some of the features that
enable games to work together with the
hardware network to deliver a truly
next-generation experience
vision for a ps5 user experience is
simple
we believe that your play time is
valuable and should be meaningful
playstation team members from all around
the world work to deliver a ps5
experience
that is completely centered on you the
player
connecting you with a great play and a
passionate community of gamers
with a look and feel that's designed for
4k tvs
the ps5 user experience was both from
the ground up to take advantage of the
console capabilities
complementing the transformative games
coming with this new generation
i should note that this video tour is
from a pre-production
environment on the ps5 console so there
may be a few small
wrinkles or minor changes once the
console launches in november
and now let's check it out courtesy of
our own sid human
thanks nishino-san welcome to your new
playstation 5
console experience this time we've
started up from rest mode
we've already created an account and
signed into playstation network so let's
login
[Music]
in this case i've resumed right where i
left off in sac boy
a big adventure and here we're looking
at playstation 5's
control center from here it's one click
and we're right back into the game
but let's take a moment and look around
the control center is always one tap of
the playstation button away
it provides immediate access to almost
everything you need from the system
without leaving the game this includes
things like seeing who is online
checking the status of a download
managing your controller power
and more
[Music]
these colorful characters are called
cards
and they let you interact with games and
the system in a variety of ways first
as we've just resumed the control center
is showing a special card that allows me
to get up to date on recent stories
posted by publishers for games i am
following
[Music]
another card here shows me recent media
i've captured from my gameplay
using the create button on the dual
sense controller
let's check out one of the most powerful
new features of the ps5 console
they're actually just to the right in
this row and we call them
activities activities are part of the
plan to remove
barriers to gameplay let's get an
example of one way they're used in sac
boy a big adventure
with the tap of the playstation button
i'm back to playing the game
sacboy a big adventure is packed with
things to discover
and each level represents one type of
activity i can play
many of which i can go back to later to
discover more
[Music]
i tap the playstation button to bring up
the control center again
i can see a number of available
activities both active
and suggested by the system let's take
this first one a big adventure
as an example i could see that i haven't
quite completed this level yet
i'm at 33 let's open it up and see more
here i can see more information
including key objectives i haven't met
and i'm seeing a very important piece of
information here it says
about 10 minutes left this is
playstation 5's
personalized playtime estimate giving me
an idea how long it will take me
to complete this activity
some activities even let you jump
directly to that place in the game
but there's more to see here for another
example let's open that activity backup
[Music]
it looks like i missed an objective to
find the monk robes costume piece
looks like i need a little help some
in-game activities
like this one offer official game help
game help is included as a benefit for
active playstation plus members in some
ps5 games
in this case i can open up that
objective to get some hints without
resorting to a web search
or digging through long videos or
articles that might contain
spoilers this particular hint is a video
and i can play it here in the card and i
can expand it to get a bigger view
without leaving the game
sometimes it's really useful to be able
to see the hint on screen while you play
some cards can be put in a picture in
picture mode
or as shown here a side by side view
super cool and if you pin a card you can
access it via the control center at any
time
now let's go find those rascally monk
robes
thanks game help
[Music]
the team at playstation wanted to make
it really easy to chat with your friends
on the playstation 5 console
so let's check out how it works here i'm
opening an interactive notification with
the tap of the playstation button
and i've decided to join the voice chat
that my friend just entered
now my friend could have done this on
the playstation app for mobile devices
from a ps4
or in this case from a ps5 the dual
sense controller features an integrated
microphone too so i could start talking
right away
but i always have the ability to hit the
mute button on the controller or in the
menus
parties take on an expanded role with
ps5
and they now provide persistent spaces
to connect with groups that you play
with
here i have a couple of friends chatting
away in the party
one of them has started sharing their
screen with the group
looks like they're playing uncharted the
lost legacy
we can chat while we play and i can
watch his progress as well
[Music]
this is another card that can be put in
picture-in-picture mode
or pinned to the side while you play you
can access it anytime via the control
center too but let's dismiss it for now
okay let's review so far we've seen how
activities on ps5 will make it easier
and
faster to hop back into ps5 games and
how you can get in-game help and chat
with your friends
so that leaves online multiplayer gaming
let's check it out
i see that some of my friends are online
so it's time to say goodbye to sac boy
for now
and spin up a match of destruction
all-stars
one of my friends in the party has
already started a match and we can join
them
from this card in control center
[Music]
and there we go destruction all-stars
now quickly starts thanks to ps5's
ultra high speed ssd
okay i think we've got enough people on
our party so let's jump in
we're keeping the focus on ps5's user
experience today so
let's zip ahead so we can see more
and just like that we're in we don't
have time to play a full match today
but i do think we have time to take a
quick photo to do that
i'll just tap the create button on the
dual sense controller
ps5 is always capturing recent gameplay
but when you compose a shot even using
in-game photo mode
you can capture a high quality
screenshot here this optimizes capturing
the moment
letting you review and choose to share
later on i
should mention screenshots and video can
be captured at up to 4k on the ps5
console
ok so far we've shown off how to jump
into activities
how to chat with your friends get into
groups together to play
capturing game play all of that while in
game
but what if i want to play a different
game
welcome to the playstation 5 home screen
this is where you'll land when you start
up from a powered off state
and where you'll go when you want to
choose a new game to play or download
the layout of the space is designed to
present games and game content
beautifully on a 4k
display with simple and super fast
access to what you need
and in case you're wondering media
related apps will have their own space
like this one but today we're focused on
gaming
each game has its own hub completely
integrated so all you need to do is
scroll down to see activities you can
jump
right into video clips stories about the
game
dlc and more backward compatible ps4
titles will benefit from some of these
features too
let's move one spot to the left and
check out explore
which brings together all your games we
saw a view of this from the control
center earlier and another view will
also be in the new playstation app for
mobile devices
explore keeps you in the loop with
official stories from playstation
and from all the games you're following
including trending media from the
community
we'll be testing and learning about this
feature in the us at launch
so not everyone will have this on day
one but it gives you a good idea of the
direction
and this is playstation store for ps5
it's completely integrated into the
system it's not a standalone app anymore
browsing for new games to play will be
easier thanks to the speed of ps5 and a
more personalized store experience
and here you'll be able to browse the
latest games and deals
you'll find ps5 games and many backward
compatible ps4 games too
i'm sad to say but we are almost out of
time so let's pull up control center one
more time with the tap of the
playstation button
on our way out why don't we quickly
share that photo we took in destruction
all-stars
we can find recently captured media in
this handy card in control center
from here we can do some quick edits but
i think i'm ready to share it right now
on playstation 5 i have the option to
share videos and images to supported
external services
or i can send them directly to one of my
parties remember
parties are bigger than just voice chat
now so i'll select one of my favorite
parties here
[Music]
let's attach a quick message here the
dual sense controller makes this
really easy playstation 5 supports
voice dictation in a number of languages
so you no longer
have to type messages with the keyboard
if you don't want to
simply select the microphone button
here's a cool detail
if my friend hasn't yet played the
activity where i captured this media
and the games developer thinks that
activity might contain spoilers
they'll receive a warning before they
view it well that's it for our demo
there are many more exciting features we
couldn't get to today but we're super
excited to share more of the playstation
5 and playstation app user experience
with you in the coming weeks headed to
launch
and of course this was just a first look
at what fans could expect on day one
the team at playstation is committed to
evolving this experience
with our community in the months ahead
we look forward to sharing more
thanks for watching